Bill Maher of HBO's real-time is in a
bit of a controversy on Friday he used
the n-word and is receiving pretty
widespread backlash for it and the
backlash is justified he should not have
said what he said but there is a double
standard here if this had been a right
winger with a show who did this
I believe liberals would have been
calling for his head Nebraska senator
Ben Sasse was on the show it was one of
those one-on-one segments that Bill
Maher does earlier in the program and
they were talking about Halloween
senator Ben Sasse says something about
Oh Nebraska would love to have Bill
Maher work in the fields and here is
what Bill Maher said in response be a
kid thing it's not anymore
not out here no adults dressed up for
Halloween they don't do that in Nebraska
it's frowned upon yeah we don't do that
quite as much but Wow I've gotta get to
Nebraska more you're welcome
we'd love to have you work in the fields
with us working this part of that Senate
I'm a house [ __ ]
it wasn't funny it really didn't make
that much sense
it was obviously off-the-cuff it wasn't
even really like a politically incorrect
joke I just didn't find it funny and
Bill Maher issued a statement through
his publicist apologizing the word was
offensive and I regret saying it and I'm
very sorry
HBO called that inexcusable and Tate
lists tasteless and they're basically
right now some people are saying oh you
know what progressives are going easy on
Bill Maher and they're not criticizing
him because he's a liberal and they're
saying if Bill Maher had been a
conservative host in that situation
everyone would be furious and that's a
double standard and therefore Bill Maher
should lose his show I don't think Bill
Maher should lose his show I don't agree
with Bill Maher's usage of the n-word
here it came across sounding racist and
he shouldn't have done it but I think
that anyone is understandably going to
interpret this differently than if a
conservative with a history of working
against racial justice had said it Bill
Maher has spent his entire career
denouncing racism and I personally feel
totally confident saying I don't think
Bill Maher is a racist because he said
this word and he is a comedian who's
known for pushing the envelope and
saying things that are controversial I'm
not defending him saying this okay I
think it was stupid and inappropriate
and there probably is a discrepancy in
how progressives are reacting because it
was Bill Maher and not Jeff Sessions or
whoever but I also think that this does
not mean Bill Maher is personally
someone who thinks less of black people
by virtue of them being black I just
think that because there's been this
sort of reclamation of the n-word within
some members of the black community
particularly sometimes comedians that
other comedians who perhaps are white or
just not black may try to push the
envelope and say it themselves sure and
it was just not it's just not a good
taste no it just it really wasn't funny
when I watched it I didn't say wow
that's a really funny joke and I can see
how some people might be upset by it it
really just wasn't funny so listen
bottom line I don't think it was okay I
don't think it would be right to end the
career of Bill Maher for this but it
probably should end the career of
someone like Jeff Sessions right it's if
you look at Jeff Sessions and his
history of what he advocated for him the
concerns are on racism when he failed to
beacon
from for a judgeship decades ago and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah if all of a
sudden he said something like this it's
perfectly fair to react differently than
if Bill Maher says it I wouldn't have
expected this from Bill Maher although
you can kind of tell that he doesn't
think about what he's saying
sometimes this seemed to me frivolous
comedic ly unnecessary and really white
people shouldn't be using the n-word and
he was right to apologize even though he
basically phoned in the apology it was
emailed to his publicist or something
like that but I I think the real crime
here is that it really just wasn't good
comedy today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS